[Music]
my pregnant friend called me the other
day she's like Emily I think I'm gonna
have my baby at home yeah I think I'm
gonna have a home birth yeah that is a
disgusting way to lose your security
deposit
that is a very difficult thing to
explain just like uh it was delivery not
DiGiorno I don't have any kids myself
I'm a pretty big fan of birth control I
understand when some people like birth
controls against my religion it's
against my religion I'm like really are
you are you serious like seriously
seriously I mean because uh not getting
pregnant is the only thing I pray about
I go to church on Christmas and Easter
and weeks I'm late they're like you take
the pill you're going to hell
well that sounds way better than
watching frozen two thousand times I
don't believe in absence I don't but it
is it's my favorite Christian argument I
love it anytime they're like hey stay a
virgin
you'll never get pregnant that is
inaccurate
isn't it Christian's
like it's a hundred percent effective
well then someone's rounding up ok
absence fails and when it fails it's
called Christmas yeah we exchange gifts
on abstinence failure day not that into
Jesus probably as my experiments
probably just me I just don't think he's
that different from every guy I've ever
dated pretty similar right just a dude
going here some wine yeah I hope you're
cool with all my rules
like really Jesus I got to go to your
place again this weekend there are just
so many pictures of your mom there you
can't make fun of Jesus he's coming back
yeah Jesus promises his second coming
yeah every guy does
[Applause]
my mom's pretty awesome she's amazing my
birthday this year she got me these
really expensive crystal wine glasses I
was like mom I don't drink wine from
glasses wine comes its own glass a box
some single surprise I'll do a pretty
bad breakup last year yeah let's talk
about it okay here we go this what
happened we were living together he
moved out then he waited till I went out
of town snuck back into the apartment
and stole the internet modem dude just
take a pair of my panties like a normal
crazy ex-boyfriend who steals a modem I
didn't know I had one till you stole it
what is I didn't know what to do so I
called the cops and they were like we
don't care they're like you realize
there are people being murdered and I
said I do realize that I'm calling to
ask if I can have one of their modems
two weeks you guys I couldn't get
internet two whole weeks that's fun
every day on the phone with the cable
company was like hey I need Internet and
they're like technically you have
internet at your apartment okay then I'm
gonna need more Internet
and they're like but you have internet
no no I do not your internet it comes to
my wall I need to get it out of my wall
and they're like have you turned - have
you tried turning the wall off and
turning it back on again is it like
weird fire while you can't get by she
was like maybe you have some sort of
crazy porn virus I was like I do have a
porn virus it took my goddamn modem
[Applause]
you